let's talk about the best financial
advice ever now
you know david you've been with me we've
interviewed a lot of people on the
streets i do a lot of man on the street
saw's on the street talking money all we
talk is money all we talk is money and i
ask people all the time what's the best
financial advice you've ever received so
you know who jacked my idea cnn i'll see
you in court cnn
right
and they ask their readers the best at
financial advice that you've ever
received and there's seven answers and
we're going to highlight them right now
you tell me if you agree and what these
are all right so let's just go down this
list let's compare them to what the
answers you got as well we can do that
let's do it so number one don't just
pocket your raise invest half of it into
your 401k
every time
so this particular uh
different readers said this by the way
different subscribers to cnn
in vast hat invest half of every raise
you get into you max out your
contributions contributions are
currently about i think a 401k is 19 000
a year and then you can get a match on
top of that up to i don't know maybe six
percent of your salary whatever it is
you'll be glad you did and would be
crazy to pass up the free money from
your company match totally agree it's
free money it's free money there's ain't
nothing better than free money it's like
they always say if you were walking down
the street and saw a hundred dollar bill
you're just gonna walk right over it
that's free money that's your 401k
another piece of advice this is what i
always tell people if you're making 50
grand as an example you get a raise and
now you're making 70. don't spend the
extra 20.
keep living for the next six months 12
months just like you're
making that 50. you did it then you'll
do it now
now you got 20 extra grand in your life
you can do whatever you want saving wise
build your wealth save that money build
your wealth that's my advice so don't
just pocket your raise invest half of it
in your 401k that's number one number
two
if you can't pay for it
pay in full for what you're buying don't
charge it totally agree with this
credit card should be used as a
financial convenience not a crutch
never carry a balance on a credit card
due to the high interest rate of course
we just talked about 10 signs of your
debt is out of control high interest
rates not a good look so you've heard
this a million times i'm sure you're
here to get on the uh this episode if
you can't buy it in full
right then and there there's no need to
charge it okay because then you're just
gonna be making payments going down that
rabbit hole the payment payment payment
payment payment debt debt debt not a
good look
number three it's never too late to
invest i agree to a certain extent so
here's a story a decade ago 55 year old
michael blaunt
made his first real foray into investing
nearing retirement from a 23-year-old
career in the military we salute you he
decided to invest a small amount of
money with a broker okay his bet and his
timing
has paid off quite
well he said he was fortunate to buy
amazon at 800 bucks a share and today i
think it's somewhere around uh like 3
600 bucks i want to say so things have
appreciated nicely
um
you know jeff bezos says
pick your investments on uh companies
that are going to change the world
amazon has certainly changed the world
so no matter your age you'll see where
they'll take off so anyway it's never
too late to invest but obviously
investing in your 20s and your 30s is a
lot better than getting started in your
50s especially if you want to retire a
millionaire number four budget for all
your needs including fun
funds are part of your budget well you
know they say there's a 50 30 20 rule
um 50 to your needs 30 to your wants 20
to your debt and your savings respect so
try to stick to it a budget or a diet in
this in this regard
if you're going to use like an eating
analogy
so you can eat what you really love
and not waste your time and going to
blow it all right it's the same true of
a hyper strict budget so basically
there's a there's a food analogy that
they use here yeah like you know if
you're going to do a diet aka a budget
for your weight
you know
stick to it but you know if you want
some chocolate ice cream once in a while
have some ice cream not a big deal
budget in some fun budget and some ice
cream not a big deal treat yourself
exactly number five retirement is easy
to solve if you start saving in your 20s
hello
that's me kind of the whole reason we're
doing this show for our 20 and
30-somethings out there yeah retirement
is easy if you solve for saving in your
20s gary anderson
not the kicker from back in the day you
wouldn't get that reference he credits
his dad from teaching him the importance
of saving for retirement
early on
he started nagging me and nagging me he
says from the moment i got my first job
out of college i wasn't that great with
money we get it in my early 20s i can't
say that i immediately took his advice
but i did
hear it
and as i got a little more comfortable
financially
in my late 20s so it took him you know a
handful of years i started upping my
401k contributions
with every pay raise until it was maxed
out respect to you gary anderson we've
said it before we'll say it again the
earlier you start the better off you'll
be compound interest is gonna kick in
compound interest the eighth wonder of
the world albert einstein what a guy the
less stressed you'll be in retirement
when it's time to actually retire no big
deal number six
never spend money behind your spouse's
back
so before you get married make an
agreement with your spouse
to be that you will never spend money
behind each other's back obviously you
know people say communication and money
are like the two things that people
fight about like you're not talking
enough you don't communicate you know
you under communicate you over
communicate you talk too much you don't
talk enough you don't tell me what's on
your mind that's number one yeah number
two money issues spending so now you're
talking about not communicating about
money well you're asking for kiss to
death bro yeah you're asking for kiss to
death so spending behind your mouth your
spouse's back is is
is defying the marriage contract they
put it wow and we'll land you in divorce
court all right maybe we don't need to
go that far that's not a good look no
but it's true that's true all right
number seven
family is always more important than
money
interesting elliot pepper aka fresh of
the pepper said that the most important
financial wisdom
his in-laws ever imparted him was that
they would pay for far-flung relatives
to travel to family gatherings
cool and the most
most impressive was how well they
supported their own aging parents
the money my in-laws
had was not just for them to be
comfortable anyways they're basically
saying look there's bigger things in
life
there's family
la familia familia la familia
okay yeah
no yeah they're i mean yeah
if you're gonna put those two against
each other yeah i would say i mean
depending on how close you are with your
family all right so just to recap this
number one but loving your aunt a lot
won't take bring down your debt so thank
you
immediate family immediate family family
first
same number one don't just pocket your
raise invest it into your 401k number
two if you can't pay for it in full
then don't charge it okay number three
it's never too late to invest number
four budget for all your needs including
fun
number five retirement is easy to solve
if you start saving your twenties
oh yeah
number six never spend money behind your
spouse's back and number seven family is
more important than money
all we talk is money
if you enjoyed that short clip from the
sauce cast click here to watch another
click here to watch the full episode or
just stay broken